a já está ligado agora é fato que já ia
começar a cortar a cabeça alguns
elementos da organização por ter
enganado no meu nome porque puseram o
nome do meu pai primeiro eo nome da
minha mãe que me espanta tudo bem todos
culpados é eu venha que um carro né na
mesma linha da apresentação dos antes
dos anteriores picas vai falar um carro
na minha experiência de como é que foi
eu decidir a dada altura e agora vou ser
empreendedores agora é é espetacular uma
palavra bonita toda a gente gosta de ser
empreendedor por ser empreendedor e
todos querem ser empreendedor é tentar
ser empreendedor mudou completamente a
minha vida é minha maneira de pensar em
minha maneira de ser é em 2009 eu decidi
criar uma empresa de consultoria
ambiental chamada nota o plano nome de
um morcego raro em portugal eu estou lá
vão 16 na altura que é uma coisa
estranha eu perguntava o filhinho mas
pagam para entrar dentro de minas
abandonadas e contatos dos morcegos
era uma coisa estranha ou não conseguia
e uma necessidade na altura é porque
havia muitos parques eólicos aparecer no
país e via morcegos e aves a começar a
parcimônia nos pareceu realmente era uma
necessidade no mercado os produtores por
exemplo interno vagas por exemplo tinham
que perceber porquê que os músicos
estavam a morrer nos dois parques
seaworld
então eu sei que é um serviço estranho
mas era um serviço que na altura era
necessário criar uma empresa estudar
seus museus esteve internado e sinop
então o que eu comecei a fazer comecei a
criar a empresa quando comecei a criar a
empresa nos primeiros tempos eu ia muito
é e eu precisava me inspirar eu
precisava de que sentia que o pedro
estava a dizer que era eu sou ainda hoje
o único sócio eu tenho uma série uma
equipa a trabalhar comigo mas eu
continuo a ser o único sócio não
pretende ser o único sócio o resto da
vida mas ainda não tem mais ninguém
comigo mas de facto como eu comecei a
trabalhar
sozinho eu sentia que o pedro que eu vou
dizer que não tinha com quem partilhar a
fé é aquela mão caídas e experimentar
estevão sangue ou aquelas decisões de
correu mesmo mal
então eu fugi ava nunca nos livros então
comecei a ler livros do gênero as minhas
vendas são estúpidas porque precisava de
idéias é este teve por exemplo aprenda
com a máfia ensinava ensinam truques
muito úteis para eu perceber como é que
a máfia novas coisas empreste dinheiro
com uma taxa de justiça durante o x
tempo não pagar logo os macs um deles
como é o que dizem os seis meses temos
uma coisa a ver com os negócios têm
portanto este senhora e já vou explicar
este senhor é é um tipo mafioso que
ganhou o o gosto pela leitura e pela
escrita na prisão e eu mostra como é que
a mapfre uma grande empresa uma viagem
linda como uma grande empresa como é que
máquinas pode ser útil a alguns algumas
das técnicas eo a área dos negócios mas
depois sempre dentro da huíla ou seja
não matar um cliente se eu não pagar a
30 dias
mas eu posso deixar de prestar serviço
inicialmente eu enviei uma fatura
surpresa com juros de mora e eu fiquei
surpreendido início existe uma louca ii
portanto há aqui uma série de coisas
interessantes nos livros que os livros
começaram a ensinar estratégias
comerciais network nossa aqui que era a
primeira coisa que eu tinha que fazer eu
fumava para as empresas para tentar a
que nas vezes em que eu queria
apresentar os meus serviços
mas dava sempre com o mesmo problema com
a senhora secretária que me perguntava
quem devo anunciar duas perguntas
margens quem devo anunciar vos antes da
empresa nokia orgulhoso uma empresa e
pode evitar o assunto são sempre as duas
perguntas margem que assim é que eu
tenho uma empresa de prestação de
serviços da você está em um parque
eólico no saque e deve contar a história
do vasco
a área que escutaria ser crivo doutora
soltou não vai aturar a mente que a
secretaria passa chamada então aquela
luzinha até me comercial está aqui ea
grana o momento por favor o que quer
dizer neste momento é apenas um momento
porque ela vai fazer o espera não vai
passar chamada para lado nenhum
afinal algum tempo eu recebia é
novamente a simpatia por faouzi que o
pedro e assim olha o engenheiro está
numa reunião é vai ter que ligar mais
tarde ela já vai acontecer o mesmo vocês
tentam entrar em contacto com a urina as
empresas mesmo quando estão a fazer uma
candidatura de emprego
ninguém está numa reunião tem que ligar
mais tarde e ele tem que ligar mais
tarde um grande truque porque a maior
parte das pessoas quando são recusadas a
primeira já não volta a ligar jazz
enganam elas próprias e depois não eu
não tenho pensado não vale a pena este
não valeu a pena
estamos nós enganar o cérebro é
implantarmos a volta ao nosso cérebro
então eu voltar outra vez os livros não
tenho que ver que um truque passar isto
você não consegue apresentar o meu
serviço
se eu mandar um e mail sem falar com
alguém primeiro eu vai prosperar ou vai
alguém tenho um vício no novelo na tecla
hewitt e apaga o meu irmão então eu lhe
mais coisas e encontrei achava eu tinha
encontrado a solução que é voltar a
secretária e tinha conseguido mostrar a
secretária que eu conhecia o engenheiro
vítor costa com quem eu queria falar
então eu vou contar o que eu fiz um bom
dia
a empresa eo álbum dia não desculpa o
meu tom de voz foi diferente não foi
assim não foi ao havaí onde foi ao bom
dia
um dia fui falar com isso achou rui
alves
vou chamar rui deixa ele falar com rui
silva e rui pessoal é uma amiga da
família
não penso certamente quer um novo que
estava a falar com o engenheiro o foco
isso achou é assim e quem deve anunciar
pelo silva santos da nokia para que esta
voz é uma coisa pelo seu o sambista não
é outra coisa mais fofa pode adiantar o
assunto e eu respondi
o rio já está à espera que o eleitor e
1932 louco e eu vou explicar por que
vamos andar para trás uma semana numa
terça feira
qual é o melhor dia para contactar as
empresas saiba no domingo não segunda
saída quintela snipes ainda estão todos
mais bêbados que não vale a pena
a segunda não porque na segunda turma e
rita não acabaram os trabalhos tinham
pra acabar na semana anterior
os forçoso o cobrador externo não
entregaram todo horas tem não sei
quantos a pressionar e pois é aquela
coisa de toques passa aquela coisa para
que mostram que a terceira a quarta
feira as coisas nas empresas estão mais
competitivas importantes e organizaram
com ênfase nas manas os pendentes já
estão resolvidos e então eu tive nem
sempre à terça-feira e se precisa fazer
mais umas chamadas em detalhe quarta
feira disponível e uma terça feira
anterior é esta chamada
escrevi um maior o engenheiro rui disso
veta tá sobre o projeto
nós temos um projeto igual tanto temos
vão em cintos antes e podemos conseguir
apresentar as propostas competitivas e
termina e malcon durante a próxima
semana o ig para falar sobre este
assunto e quando é assim né perguntou
posso adiantar o assunto disse
o rio já está à espera que ele lê e ela
passou uma chamada
do outro lado atendendo o sni ruim assim
sim gil engenheiro ruy para comemorar
pois o general carneiro quer falar com
rui engenheiro ruim e sim ó pedro silva
antes da nokia mantém o irmão a semana
passada por isso sim diga diga de
alimentação ou não eu o meu irmão não
deu atenção nenhuma
mas eu não posso chamar mentiroso porque
eu terminei com durante as próximas mas
não ligue pra falar sobre as pessoas
então consegui passar simples cantaria
25 senhor já está à espera que eu li
porque a gravar este era um dos truques
que o que eu queria partilhar com vocês
depois o conselho tem um problema a
resolver o primeiro problema conseguir
passar a secretária mas depois o
problema nas nas reuniões comerciais que
consegue reparar nas reuniões comerciais
têm todos um vizinho que essa onda no
seu cartão zin estivessem a usar cartas
para iniciar o jogo da sueca estão todos
a distribuir cartões e eu não tinha
cartão e saxofones vão inventar uma
história e disse sabe nós como empresa
de consultoria ambiental é queremos que
a nossa pegada ecológica soja é
relativamente reduzido então não fazem
os campeões levam vista que treta ou
seja reinventado aquela história de que
ivan e suas compreendiam as depois
pensei estamos província porque o
investidor aproveita para contar a
história
e explica porque não têm cartões porque
tem uma reza um cartão de frente que eu
decidi fazer como fazer com os livros
andei na internet à procura de cartões
de idosos
então encontrei um cartão de um
fotógrafo muito engraçado um cartão de
um cirurgião implantes mamários não é
uma coisa imposta mas mesmo assim
expandir suas vendas ea que andava com
as minhas pra frente e encontrei a ficar
tão engraçado ver um advogado de
divórcios que é um cartão que têm a
mesma informação do lado direito eo lado
esquerdo então tem um pib estável rasga
e diz tomar para si e tomar para o seu
futuro
o ex marido é esquentado uma loja de
bicicletas e serve fã e eu pensei em
criar um cartão tenham outro levava mas
eu não consegui encontrar utilidade
nenhuma então decidi fazer uma coisa
após algumas reuniões daquela história
da pegada ecológica não temos cartão não
sei que reparei que vinham teatral volta
dos cartões que para além desta
distribuição de cartas para jogar à
sueca eu reparei que os faziam sempre em
vantagem
vão o cartão à altura dos olhos
continuam a ouvir a pessoa tocavam na
van em jeito de aprovação continuavam a
ouvir as outras pessoas viravam cartão a
tentar perceber se existe alguma coisa
no verso e normalmente não existia usava
na mesa até o fim da reunião e no final
da reunião
cava e suporta cartões e eu pensei vou
fazer uma coisa gira então se fazem
estas coisas quando a pessoa pega no
cartão em fases teatro tem uma pessoa à
frente ao ela faz o mesmo teatro que
acontece essa pessoa fizer isto e estava
à frente e vir que há alguma coisa no
verso do cartão vai tender a virar o
cartão eu tenho que acontece diversas
descartam for livre todos os cartões
tiveram um verso de frente as pessoas
não o meu é diferente então isso o que
acontece eu puser imagens para as
compras ainda mais para nós no cartão
então pedi várias coisas ao nosso design
olha o essencial a imagem de uma auto
estrada diz a mesma passada e coloca um
curso atravessar a passadeira
não faz sentido nenhum exato mas é isso
mesmo que depois coloca uma pergunta
como é que os animais através das auto
estradas
até mesmo parar né ou seja na certeza
que elas não atravessam as auto estradas
numa passadeira e é aqui que nós criamos
querem vir não estar a explicar que não
tinha cartões porque tinha uma pegada
ecológica não sei que reduzida e
explicar porque os nossos cartões tinham
imagens estranhas com perguntas ainda
mais estranhas e os nossos serviços
respondiam a estas perguntas e é muito
fácil colocar esta pergunta no google
vai obter resposta
acredita podem fazer este exercício a
que lugo como é que os animais
atravessam as auto-estradas e vão dar
diretamente ao nosso site e dentro do
nosso site
nós vamos disponhamos existem passagens
superiores passagens inferiores como é
que nós sabemos onde é que animais antes
de construir auto-estradas são serviço
nós postamos temos aquelas câmeras com
sensores de movimento como nós vemos no
national geographic colocamos em
determinados locais
vemos que animais é que passam decidimos
onde é que tentem colocar as passagens
superiores inferiores e tem como é que
eu sei que os animais passam lá
exatamente nós também gostamos dos
serviços depois da autoestrada está
construída
colocamos as câmeras ou seja agora eu
podia falar sobre os cartões que eram
diferentes tinham imagens paga para ver
com pergunta estranha e os nossos
serviços respondiam é isto
ok e depois fomos nós temos cada vez
mais apostar em mais vezes mais
diferentes com perguntas ainda mais para
baixo ou seja colocar 11 uma imagem do
mundo conforme nós o conhecemos
a goya dentro de uma garrafa que estava
em águas turvas
depois colocamos a pergunta este mundo
está proibido para falar ainda não está
mas temos que ter atenção às alterações
climáticas e nené é tem que ser visto é
que nós prestamos está e está no site
coloco isso no google e vão dar as
respostas estão no site
o parceiro ou seja eu criei uma coisinha
volta dos cartões para várias pessoas ao
nosso site
temos exatamente a mesma coisa com os
cadernos nós no início de cada reunião
temos os cabelos em cima da mesa assim
como é que os animais através das
auto-estradas uma pasta vai certamente
não é está insuficientemente estranho
para está no início de uma reunião e
estamos a reunir este mundo está
proibido a coisa mais estranha alguém
tem um caderno com uma cabeça muito está
por vivo plantão não quero ficar muito
mais
é o que eu consegui fazer se de criar um
site chamado núcleo palaciano feno e que
só desde o início defende o que
interessa deve ser partilhado
nós partilhamos a série de idéias novas
dicas
estas dicas que estava aqui temos uma
selecção como vencer eu falar como é que
ia voltar a secretária para começar a
entrar nas empresas como é que se
construiu esta esta coisa toda a volta
do cartão tradicional ponto como e ii
basicamente esta é minha vida tem sido
recheada de experimentar para juízes e
muitas não resultaram e outras não
resultaram em andamento e pronto e acho
que os negócios é isso mesmo